'"When your legs don't work-'" (Chika
sneezes and distracts Mark)
'"When your legs don't work like they used to before,
and I can't
sweep you off of your feet,
will your mouth still remember the taste of my love?
Will your eyes still smile from your cheeks?
And darling, I will
be loving you
till we're seventy.
Baby, my
heart could still fall as hard
at 23.
I'm thinking 'bout
how people fall in love
in mysterious
ways, maybe just the touch of a hand.
Well, me? I keep on loving
you every single day
I just want
to tell you I am.
So, honey now,
take me into your loving arms,
kiss me under the light of
a thousand stars,
place your hand on my
beating heart.
I'm thinking out loud,
maybe we found love
right where
we are.
When my hair's all but gone and my memory fades,
and the crowds don't remember my name,
when my hands don't play the strings the same way,
I know you will still love me the same.
'Cause, honey, your
soul will never grow old,
it's evergreen.
Mm, baby, your
smile forever in
my mind, in memory
oooh
I'm thinking 'bout how
people fall in love
in mysterious
ways
maybe it's all part of a plan
Me? I'll keep on making the same
mistakes,
hoping that
you'll understand.
Baby, now
ooh
take me into your loving arms,
kiss me under the light of a thousand stars,
place your hand on my beating heart,
thinking out loud.
Maybe we found love right where we are,
ooh
la, la, la, la, la, la
(quiet humming)
So, baby, now
take me into your loving arms
kiss me under the light of a thousand stars,
place your hand on my beating heart,
thinking out loud.
Maybe we found love right
where we are.
Maybe we found love right where we are.
Maybe we found love right where we are.'"
(to Chica) "Was it that bad?"
(laughing) "Good girl."
"Oh who's a fluffy pupper?"
"This is- uh, um, that
this is that secret project that terrifies me.
Uh, it may not seem like a lot, I know.
I know it's got a lot of mistakes, and I know there's a lot of stuff I can improve on, but
um
by my own standards, this is a big step forward for me.
I haven't preformed musically in, uh
in front of people
since high school, and that was a nightmare.
So, this was a big psychological hurdle to even get to this point,
where- where I've only been taking this seriously for about three months
now. But this is what I want to be doing on the tour.
Like- uh, if you want more tickets, we added second shows
where it sold out. So check out markiplier.com
or, um,
go to the link in the description below, there'll be stuff down there that'll show you.
I mean, not the whole tour we also have a comedy show
that we're doing with it. But this is- uh- this was a personal challenge for me.
Because, it's one of those moments where I know my weakness.
And my weakness is this, like performing
in something that's not just me going on stage and talking,
which you guys know I can do till the sun goes dead.
Um, but when it comes to
performing like this, knowing it's not perfect,
and knowing I'm not great at it,
it's...um,
I don't know.
I'm really proud of myself.
I think that's cool. Don't expect my channel to suddenly
change into only covers. I- I do this
because it's a good challenge for me and it's a great expression
of creativity. And it's something that
really, really drives me. And where a lot of my life
I have improved myself substantially,
this is one of the areas that I have let myself regress.
So, I don't want to shy away from it just because I'm afraid of failing at it.
I want to pursue it and I want to hit it hard and I want to show you guys.
I want to present this to you because
that's what it's all about.
That's what youtube's all about, like showing you me,
where I am not perfect.
I can, at least, improve a bit.
That's cool. So anyway, let me know what you guys think. It's-
There's- it could be bad, could be good,
I don't really care, give it to me straight,
I am my own worst critic anyway, so it's not like you guys could be any worse.
I want to know what you guys think.
I- I think this is fun.
I want to do what makes me happy.
And right now, this does. Even if it aggravates me to no end when I'm
wrong. But, it's cool.
So, thanks for watching guys.
Write what you think down in the comments below.
As always, I'll see you in the next one.
Buh-bye!"
(strums guitar)